بدات سرق الدفاع المدنيه السوري مرحله
البحث وانتشال الضحايا من تحت الانقاض في
المناطق التي تعرضت للزلزالي بشكل قوي في
مناطق الشمالي غربيه سوريا عشرات العائلات
ما زالت تحت انقاضي هذه المباني نحن في حي
القشا في مدينه حارم حيث تهدم اكثر من 85
منزلا سكنيا فوق رؤوس ساكنين فرق الدفاع
المدني السوري في الايام الماضيه كانت قد
انتشلت اكثر من عشره اشخاص ناجين من هذه
المباني واليوم تستكمل لانتشال الضحايا
العالقين تحت هذه الانقاذ هناك عشرات
الاشخاص من ذوي الضحايا ينتظرون خبر من
فرق الدفاع المدني السوري ربما يتحدث
الينا احدهم السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام
ورحمه الله يسلمكم يا رب مين عندك هون
حاليا والله جيراني واهلي وكل الناس وكلن
جيراننا ومهجرين يعني كلها كانت مهجرين
يعني كلياتها 5% من الاقل بس لو تفيدنا
معلومات كم عيله او كم شخص يعني تقريبا شي
ثلاث أربع عائلات هدول الموجودين شي 16
شخص هدول يعني لسه موجودين يعني تحت
الانقاذ يعني هو ما طلع حدا بس هدول يعني
تحت الانقاذ لحد الان موجودين في حدا طلع
نجا من العائلات من العائلات شي تقريبا
يعني شيء خمسه يعني تقريبا بس فقط الحمد
لله رب العالمين هي تقريبا تطلع يعني
بالحدود 80 شقه كلياتها عنا
يمكن تروح شقق هدول الموجودين الطيبين
فاقدهم بس والباقي كله شوف تعيي الملك لله
والحمد لله
تابعه وحده يعني والحمد لله نشكر الله اذا
الدمار ما هو الحقيقه والمصاب كبير هنا في
هذه المنطقه نتحدث عن عشرات العائلات التي
ما زالت تحت الركام ابتداء جنديرس في ريف
حلب وصولا الى منطقه حارم وسلقين بريف
ادلب الغربي ادهم ابو الحسام الجزيره
حارم ريفوت ليفال الغربي